a fiscal punishment intended to [ __ ]
russia's international financial
transactions a western show of unity
against the country's military assault
on ukraine
swift is the world's dominant global
interbank payment system
cutting banks off
will stop them from conducting most of
their financial transactions worldwide
and effectively block russian exports
and imports
ukraine had repeatedly called on its
western allies to sanction russia before
its forces reached the capital friday's
announcement intends to limit russia's
ability to finance the war
swift is a secure messaging system
that's used for trillions of dollars
worth of transactions and is integral to
the global economy excluding some
russian banks from that will hit their
ability to trade internationally
moscow's central bank has 600 billion
dollars of reserves and will also be
affected
while it's the biggest move yet by
western powers against the kremlin there
has been some reluctance from countries
like germany that heavily rely on russia
for oil and gas imports
this idea that this is in some way going
to be just a tax on russia
is misplaced right
trade is mutually beneficial especially
trade in the type of commodities that
the world in europe in particular buys
from russia
money transfer systems other than swift
are in place but aren't as efficient
when iran was blocked in 2014 it lost 30
percent of its foreign trade it's still
not clear when one of the most powerful
financial penalties to be imposed on
russian financial institutions will be
implemented and russia is yet to respond
al
jazeera all right we're going to live
now to uh dinipro where hodda abdul
hamid is live for us with the latest on
what's happening there hoda
well we actually in a shelter uh at the
moment because this air siren
went off and this is the first time it
goes off here in the nepa uh since this
war started um
people also just anyone who was nearby
just came in we're actually in the
basement
of a restaurant not able to show you the
rest of the people because actually they
don't want to be filmed uh they're very
worried everybody's on their smartphone
trying to figure out what's happening
you don't know exactly what's happening
there is a rumor of a
russian jet
all right
looks like we've lost a lot of their
apologies uh for that very fluid
situation there in ukraine right now
much more to come when we oh i
understand i'm just being told we do
have harder back now holla can you hear
me
okay apparently not it does appear to be
we've lost her uh we will come back with
much more still ahead on al jazeera
we will stop putin from using his war
chest
western allies agreed to cut some
russian banks from the swift financial
system
we are scared
we are alone with our daughter we don't
have a defender
we talk to some of the ukrainian
families left divided by the war
plus in sport the czech republic becomes
the latest international football team
to refuse to play against russia
[Music]
okay we're going to dispense with that
break because
well
we yep that we're gonna go now to uh
russian president vladimir putin who is
uh speaking now from uh from
western countries are taking not only
unfriendly um uh actions towards our
country in economics uh i mean the
sanctions that everyone knows about
that top officials of the leading united
countries
they are
saying the aggressive stuff towards
our country
that's why
i um
i command the minister of defense and a
chief of staff
to transfer our nuclear deterrence
forces
on high alert
just been hearing that from the russian
president uh vladimir putin uh there
with his military leaders uh uh beside
him more reaction on that to come uh
what we expect but right now we're going
to go to uh nico voribiov he is a
russian journalist and joins us live
from saint petersburg thanks very much
for being with us so i just want to ask
you just um broadly speaking what's your
assessment of of what's been happening
in ukraine over the past couple of days
and and and where you see all this going
um i mean obviously i can't i can't
speak for the the whole russian
population but everyone i know and most
people i know were in shock because we
really weren't weren't expecting this um
because up until last week the uh the
media of the the state-owned media they
were still assuring us all the talking
heads were still assuring us that there
wouldn't be a war
up until the bomb started dropping on
here we we pretty much believed we
didn't think it was gonna happen
so a lot of people are quite shocked
they know what's happening we've both
been hit with the um
the not only the sanctions but also uh
facebook and uh twitch have been shut
down uh in russia you have to use vpn to
get past there now
um we've been cut off from swift a lot
of people can't um
uh they were strong for example and they
found themselves that they couldn't pay
um
but a lot of people also prepared in
advance they started taking out cash
already in january
they're ready for the long haul
okay uh nico thanks very much uh for
that we appreciate it wonder if you can
stay with us for now because right now
we're going to go back to
uh
well we were hoping to go back to the
russian uh president
um but it appears we don't so let's
let's let's uh bring up these live
pictures that we're getting right now um
of saint petersburg of uh we showed this
to you earlier a protest um that was
taking place there against the war anika
you were
you're speaking to us from there of
course um quite a quite a number of
protesters there
who are i guess as surprised as you are
about what's unfolded over the last uh
four days and are not happy about it at
all um it looked quite chaotic there was
seeing
quite a quite a large number of security
people there um as well um just just
talk to us about
um
what your what your feelings are the
longer this conflict uh goes on and
the the sentiment felt by a lot of a lot
of russians like yourself that the
ukrainians are are essentially brothers
of of of russians
yeah and i mean um even uh president
putin he said as much himself he's even
written a
a very long essay about it last year so
it kind of um like i lived in in britain
as well right and
kind of the
when britain or america obviously i'm
against those wars as well but like when
britain and america go to war it's
usually somewhere you know thousands of
miles away uh whereas here we're
literally fighting our our neighbors on
our you know sometimes even our
relatives because a lot of russians
know a lot of
family in russia and and the other way
around
so it yeah it came came as a shock
what do you think is is the the goal of
of uh president putin here is he is he
trying to
because leading up to this
uh many people assumed that this was
just a dispute over uh eastern ukraine
and um and that's where that it wouldn't
go as any sort of conflict wouldn't go
much further than that but clearly we're
seeing a lot more of that now that he uh
that the russian forces are in uh
several cities and are bombed several
cities and so on what do you think is
the end game is he trying to encircle
the capital and perhaps replace the
government there with one that is more
compliant to him
what do you think
uh that's that's the thing i'm i'm quite
confused about that myself because like
this the stated
of the of the operation right uh the way
it's been it's being sold to to us right
now is it's a peacekeeping operation
to the the donbass of the
the rebel-held affairs of eastern
ukraine where the people genuinely have
been living in a trans state of siege or
semi-sea for the past eight years that
much is true
but then why i didn't really understand
what they
were taking here but like let's say
if we get into if we occupy kiev and we
install a public government
i mean i don't know if how is that worth
the the losses that we take on the world
stage uh the losses to our economy the
the loss in terms of
manpower i mean there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of propaganda out there
from
but from the ukrainian side maybe um the
russian side isn't releasing the death
statistics how many soldiers have died
but it's probably quite a few and this
is only beginning so even if we manage
to occupy ikea right it's gonna
install puppet regime there's gonna be a
vicious uh like a guerrilla warface the
ukrainians aren't gonna get up that easy
they're gonna get weapons from the west
they're gonna have volunteers from from
poland coming in so i'm not
sure what the what the long-term plan is
i could follow the logic of trying to
bully ukraine into staying out of nato
but i don't really understand what
uh total war would it hopes to achieve
yeah i just want to pick up on what you
said there about um that the russian
authorities are not releasing statistics
of a number of russians who've died um
but the point was made before this
conflict that if it does
uh become something larger than
clashes in eastern ukraine um and uh
there's more violence and and more
russian lives are lost this is not
something that
um they can continue to hide uh from the
russian people is it as as more um as
more russian soldiers are killed in in
the conflict there the longer this goes
on
exactly and uh also
from what i was saying earlier like when
i when britain america goes towards
usually somewhere far away so we still
have like a lot uh we still have a lot
of friends and and family in ukraine who
are uh
telling us a different version from what
we might hear in the state media so i
think it's going to be really hard to
to
hide what's what's going on
compared to somewhere like syria where
it's kind of an information black hole
good to talk to you uh nico uh vorobioff
there from st petersburg appreciate time
thanks very much
thanks very much